et le jeu à un moment donné ouais il
faut on n'est pas en contrôle de soi
tout le temps c'est un peu le contraire
du selfie quoi un moment donné non mais
c'est vrai aujourd'hui tout le monde se
contrôle on met des filtres on mélange
un tout ouais mais à un moment donné
faut lâcher parce que vous pouvez pas
être dans le contrôle ce n'est pas
possible en fait dans le contrôle tout
le temps je suis connu on gère une image
de soi mais au final on se rend compte
quelle image qu'est-ce qu'on gère quoi
au final il y a tellement de photos il y
a tellement de réseaux aujourd'hui il y
a tellement de ce que vous voulez
contrôler quoi ce chose que je peux
contrôler c'est c'est l'intériorité
c'est ce que j'essaye de dire c'est ce
que j'essaye de faire passer c'est de
contrôler en m'écoutant parler d'être au
plus près de ce que j'ai envie
d'exprimer vous voyez d'être c'est pas
du contrôle c'est
c'est d'essayer d'être au plus faire
passer quelque chose de d'authentique de
vrai quoi mais ça après je peux pas
contrôler ce qu'on va faire de tout ça
quoi et j'ai pas envie moi j'ai pas
envie de contrôler ma vie à ce niveau là
non
extrêmement présents sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est peut-être aussi une
manière de contrôler un peu ce qui donne
vous vous êtes peu présente sur les
réseaux sociaux quel rapport vous avez
que les réseaux sociaux moi j'ai le
contrôle j'ai un peu le réflexe
contraire parce que comme très très
jeune j'ai été
représenter par d'autres dans un film on
m'a identifié dans la petite vie que du
film La Boum on m'a mis une image dessus
donc les gens contrôlaient tout pour moi
en fait un peu et puis moi j'ai aussi
contrôlé un peu ma carrière qu'est-ce
que je dois faire et ça machin
et aujourd'hui je suis plutôt dans le
lâcher moi je suis plutôt dans le tout
ça tout ça c'est bon
parce que je me rends compte que créer
quoi une image créer les choses bougent
les choses sont pas statiques
on bouge soi-même on change on vieillit
on évolue
chaque jour amène quelque chose où on
lève quelque chose mais les choses sont
pas figées moi-même je m'échappe je vais
vieillir je vais avoir des cheveux
blancs qu'est-ce que je contrôle quoi
oui contrôler une bonne santé essayer de
mourir en bonne santé mais qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que je contrôle non il faut
faire confiance aussi
faut faire confiance aussi aux choses
c'est à dire si on est dans le contrôle
c'est qu'on a peur de de l'extérieur de
l'autre moi j'ai pas peur j'ai pas peur
je vais au contraire je suis curieuse
contrôler c'est se fermer à tout quoi
dans le cinéma français dans le cinéma
mondial
parce que j'ai une place
en fait je me suis plus rendu compte
plutôt que de ma place dans le cinéma
moi je me suis plutôt rendu compte la
place énorme qui avait le cinéma dans ma
vie et je suis contente en fait d'être
habité par ça parce que c'est en même
temps complètement
intangible on va dire et en même temps
ça parle que de nous des hommes des
êtres humains de des sentiments de la
beauté des choses de la tragédie aussi
le mythe
on va se calmer
les mots à avoir donné les journalistes
il faut aussi qu'ils trouvent des
nouvelles formules ou je sais pas quoi
et puis il faut du spectaculaire
toujours du spectaculaire
le mythe faudrait déjà que je sois morte
depuis longtemps et qui est plusieurs
générations qui soient passées derrière
j'ai pas quelqu'un qui rêve beaucoup
j'ai pas de rêve
je suis assez
grégaire comment dire c'est concrète
vous voyez j'ai
pas si c'est mon éducation mon milieu on
était pas trop dans le rêve on était
dans le fer
dans vas-y bouge ton cul quoi si tu veux
faire quelque chose tu y vas tu te lèves
tu vas bosser c'est pas très romantique
c'est pas très
mais en fait mon rêve ce serait de
pouvoir toujours faire
c'est à dire de garder une mobilité une
curiosité et de ne pas avoir peur
mon rêve ouais ce serait finalement de
de vivre très très vieille et en bonne
santé voilà
non peut-être pas faire du cinéma
très égoïstement j'ai envie de dire
ouais mon rêve ce serait de kiffer quoi
ma dernière partie de vie franchement
parce que c'est la dernière autant en
profiter et d'être voilà en
[Musique]
harmonie avec soi avec les gens autour
de soi qu'on aime j'ai envie d'harmonie
j'ai envie de d'amour de de
connexion j'ai envie de choses simples
en fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]